Today's Show is a very special
conversation that we had with former
child actor Jeanette McCurdy who you
know from hit Nickelodeon shows like
iCarly and Sam and Cat certainly shows
I've watched with my daughter but this
is about her best-selling Memoir it's
called I'm glad my mom died which is a
humorous bold approach about her
complicated relationship with her mother
we originally shot this interview as a
YouTube exclusive but the response has
been so incredible that we decided to
bring it to broadcast and do the entire
episode about it now Jeanette's book has
actually been on the best seller list at
number one for eight weeks in a row so
obviously our YouTube piece is not the
only thing resonating with people her
honesty her bravery her Candor but most
importantly the lessons that she's
earned and learned are what is is really
resonating with people so please welcome
a conversation that has personally
changed my life Jeanette McCurdy
I was voracious and went after you like
a crazy person wanting to have a
conversation with you because of the
things I went through in my life and
with my mom
and growing up in this industry
first of all this cover I love you so
much the humor
how did you get to the humor of this did
you earn it have you always had a sense
of humor with well with the title
specifically I always knew that I wanted
it to be called I'm glad my mom died I
wanted something that would be really
bold and attention grabbing and
hopefully that people with a sense of
humor would get you know and also I
think anybody with who's experienced
parental abuse understands and I I
didn't feel so concerned with I knew
there would be you know some people who
are like I don't get that title but I
thought that'd be that'd be totally fine
and when people maybe don't get the the
comedy and the tone yeah how do they
behave and what how does it make you
feel
um I try to stay off like Twitter but
every interview that I've done so far
the the interview has been sure to let
me know hey that title is very divisive
um and I think that anything worth
saying is probably going to be divisive
I think if it's not divisive it's
probably there's probably no new
conversation to be had there so I felt
it was an important and worthwhile title
does someone have to die in order to be
able for us to tell our truths I think
we at least have to write as if they
have died which is that old saying right
like right as if everyone you know is
dead
um I've never heard that one before I
don't know who said it but I'm pretty
sure it's it's like a I I think it's a
saying I don't think I just coined it I
know never heard it before I've
definitely heard like right as if no
one's reading it or dances if nobody's
watching I mean that's the new mug being
sold on child I'm actually asking
honestly yeah do I have to wait to tell
on my truths I don't know if I can do it
because certain people are alive my
thought on that is I think if saying the
truth ends a relationship I think it's
probably a relationship that needed to
end I guess does that make sense like
yeah it does it probably there was
probably some painful uncomfortable
truth that was just needing to be
expressed for a long time and if saying
that
out loud is going to end the
relationship I think it's probably
better off not being in a person's life
how do you get over guilt and shame if
they're still alive in order to tell
those truths um
oh my God
guilt and shame are tough I really I I
struggle to navigate guilt and shame for
a long time I would get them confused
and I was told by a therapist that I
loved that guilt can sometimes be
worthwhile because it can say oh maybe
there's a correction to be made in like
a life path or a lifestyle choice but
that shame is not really worthwhile that
it kind of keeps you stuck and can like
Spiral so I would say the shame
the shame is is is I just don't think
it's a a valuable
emotion really but I do think with guilt
do you think it's warranted guilt or do
you think it's unwarranted I think when
it comes to our moms
we want so badly to have this
relationship that I can't even say
society says we're supposed to have it
is nature it is nurture it's Evolution I
just have to say that you're amazing I
came in and I felt very sort of like
I've been doing a lot of press and I was
sort of in like press mode and kind of
like saying the thing and then just you
sharing that thank you for sharing and I
felt like just an immediate connection
and like the Press walls kind of dropped
and then I was like just like a human
moment
so much
here to ask advice I I relate to your
journey so much I feel like I have a lot
to learn from you oh man I really do I'm
so glad you said that because I don't
think of this as the same thing I I
wanted I just was like can I please talk
with her I one human being to another
yes that feeling is just yeah wow and
also I knew I could trust you because
you did have comedy in there when it's
all so dark and heavy I'm like I don't
want anything to do with you if you
haven't found this comedy as a coping
mechanism we have nothing to talk about
So when you say that I feel like I can't
take somebody seriously if they're too
serious because I'm like they don't
where's the humor like there are Shades
to reality it's never just dramatic it's
never just funny it's always layered and
messy and gunky and that's juicy you
know I couldn't agree more because as
actors you're like put it all out there
you think you're so out there but like
that dark stuff that's in there right
it's real deep and buried yes so how did
you start your therapy journey and how
did you start to unpack well initially
when I when I went to therapy I did have
my mom still on the pedestal and every
time I felt defensive immediately when
my first therapist Laura started asking
questions about my mom immediately I
went into well she did this but it's
because she's such a good mom it's
because she wanted me to be successful
it's because she wanted me to have a
better life like everything had a I I
was so defensive I didn't realize that I
was at the time but in retrospect I see
oh I was disclaiming every single thing
that my mom did instead of just stating
the reality or how I felt about it it
was I was more concerned with how I how
to keep my mom looking good than I was
with expressing my true emotional
reality okay I think of having an aha
moment Tell Me Maybe it's protectiveness
that I feel
[Music]
I've never put it in those terms in my
head wow I got chills
it's like I don't want to paint her
negatively I don't want people to think
of her negatively yes but the truth is
tough stuff
[Applause]
yeah I
it took me a long time to accept that my
mom
was not perfect let alone abusive like
it went in baby steps to to put these
pieces of the puzzle together and to
recognize the reality of the pain that
I'd suppressed for decades at that point
you know I first went there when I was
20 22 or 23. what did your therapist do
that made you feel like you could keep
going
[Music]
foreign